good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the arrival of the
chinese corona virus has killed tens of
thousands of americans and put tens of
millions more out of work really hurt
the economy badly but the crisis is also
forced to the center serious
conversations about issues that matter
to the future of the country issues like
the dangerous rise of Chinese global
dominance the porousness of our domestic
borders this country's crumbling
infrastructure government corruption and
incompetence we're talking about all of
this over the past two months you may
have asked yourself why weren't we
talking about these things before
they're important well it's a good
question and there's a simple answer to
it the answer is we didn't have time
there was no time to consider the
fundamental health of America because we
were busy talking about Russia in
Washington Russia is all we talked about
for three years
all normal business in the capital city
came to a halt as we embarked on a
bizarre scavenger hunt in search of
Vladimir Putin spies even at the time
the whole thing seemed absurd now we
know it was worse than absurd this
wasn't in fact what we thought it was
history's longest episode of mass
hysteria it was instead an elaborate and
intentional hoax staged by the most
unscrupulous and power-mad political
operatives this country has ever seen
sound like overstatement how do we know
that because they've admitted it
yesterday the House Intelligence
Committee chaired by congressman Adam
Schiff of California finally released 57
transcripts of testimony delivered to
the committee behind closed doors all of
it during the Russia investigation one
of those transcripts reveal we're not
going to ask you to trust us on this one
it's too important so instead we're
going to quote directly from the
transcripts Jim clapper Obama's Director
of National Intelligence said this quote
I never saw any direct empirical
evidence of the Trump campaign or
someone in it was plotting or conspiring
with the Russians to meddle with the
election end quote
compare that to his Twitter feed former
UN Ambassador Samantha power meanwhile
was asked by the committee if she had
any evidence of collusion with the
Russians she replied this way quote I am
NOT in possession of anything I'm not in
possession and didn't read or absorb
information that came out of the
intelligence community and quote
National Security Advisor Susan Rice
this quote I don't recall intelligence
that I would consider evidence amazing
and here's former attorney general
Loretta Lynch Lynch was asked if she saw
evidence of Russian collusion and she
replied this way quote I do not recall
that being briefed up to me
notice lunch his word choice here I do
not recall for three years our entire
political system every television show
every newspaper all media outlets
revolved around the hunt for Russian
spies
we were told again and again in order to
justify this that collusion was the
greatest crime ever committed in
American history was a crime against the
state it undermined our democracy yet
the Attorney General of the United
States a close friend of the President
Barack Obama's claims she quote does not
recall if she ever received any evidence
that any of it was true if she'd been
Roger stone when she said that she would
have been charged with perjury on the
spot we'd be watching her sentencing
right now but she's not Roger stone and
of course Lynch probably thought the
transcript of those remarks would never
be made public that was clearly Evelyn
Farkas assumption Farkas is a former
Defense Department official from the
Obama administration she became a
fixture you may remember on cable
television
as news outlets scrambled for puppets
with legitimate sounding resumes to push
the rush a collusion narrative dumb
people who would say anything and those
categories Farkas delivered in spades
here she was in March of 2017
I was urging my former colleagues and
and frankly speaking the people on the
hill I it was more actually aimed aimed
at telling the hill people get as much
information as you can get as much
intelligence as you can before President
Obama leaves the administration because
I had a fear that somehow that
information would disappear with the
senior people who left so it would be
hidden away in the bureaucracy that the
Trump folks if they found out how we
knew what we knew about their the staff
the Trump staffs dealing with Russians
that they would try to compromise those
sources and methods meaning we would no
longer have access to that intelligence
so I became very worried because not
enough was coming out into the open and
I knew that there was more we have very
good intelligence on Russia yeah mark
that's why you have the leaking it
exactly are worried all right we have
very good intelligence on Russia quote
said dr. Evelyn Farkas she can't take
your appendix out by the way she's not
that kind of doctor we knew what we knew
but she didn't know anything Farkas was
lying as purely as a liar can lie once
under oath behind closed doors Farkas
admitted that quote I didn't know
anything she said it was all lies
literally all of it even the core claims
about hacking that formed the basis of
the entire story and the investigation
that followed in 2016 during the
campaign
someone stole information from the DNC's
email server wound up online and
embarrassed Hillary Clinton Democrats
quickly blamed that theft on Russian
agents and therefore Donald Trump who
needless to say was their pawn in fact
there was never real evidence that that
actually happened
the DNC you'll remember never allowed
federal investigators to inspect their
email servers
that's odd behavior for people who claim
to be the victims of foreign espionage
instead the party servers were inspected
by a third party company called
CrowdStrike
all of this coming back to you well at
the time Adams ships committee
interviewed the CEO of CrowdStrike Sean
Henry shift question Henry directly
personally he asked if Henry knew when
the russians had stolen the data henry's
reply which we're seeing for the first
time is this quote as it relates to the
DNC we have indicators that data was
exfiltrated we did not have concrete
evidence we did not have concrete
evidence later Henry admitted he had
only quote circumstantial evidence that
the Russians were involved at all Adam
Schiff heard those words directly he
heard them from the one person who would
know for certain Schiff knew there was
nothing substantial at the core of the
Russian collusion story at the very
center it was hollow it was a sham
Schiff never even suggested this in
public
instead he did the opposite he spent
years on television telling you it was
totally real shut up
so there's clear evidence on the issue
of collusion and this adds to that body
of evidence there's ample evidence of
occlusion in plain sight and that is
true have Democrats found any evidence
of collusion yes we have you can see
evidence in plain sight on the issue of
collusion pretty compelling evidence and
there is significant evidence of
collusion there is ample evidence and
indeed there is of collusion of people
in the Trump campaign with the Russians
I think there's plenty of evidence of
collusion or conspiracy all of this is
evidence of collusion there is
significant evidence of collusion
between the campaign and Russia in case
you weren't counting during that montage
Adam Schiff said evidence nine times and
every single time he was lying and it
was fairly obvious at the time if he
were following closely Schiff never
produced any of the so-called evidence
that the DNC server or by the way John
Podesta's email were hacked by the
Russian government several times on the
show we raised the question do we really
know this a group of entired
intelligence officers what a long piece
saying actually that didn't happen and
here's how we know and we brought that
up on the show we came under enormous
pressure to be quiet
you're crazy we know that for a fact but
we didn't know it for a fact
when Schiff came on this show we asked
him how exactly do you know this he
never answered our question instead he
accused us of treason look right into
the camera and say I know for a fact the
government of Vladimir Putin was behind
the hacks of John Podesta absolutely the
government of Vladimir Putin was behind
the hacks of our institution and the
dumb John Podesta is not only in the US
but also in Europe okay you're not you
know what your dog said I know they did
and I think that Ronald rolling around
you're carrying water for the Kremlin
and you can't say you're gonna have to
move your shoulder to RT Russian
television a normal person would not
behave that way could not behave that
way conscience would prevent it
Adam Schiff is a sociopath he will do or
say anything to achieve power he is
unfit to hold office he should resign
and not just Adam Schiff the entire
apparatus of official Washington has
been exposed by these transcripts as
well as by the documents just released
in the Michael Flynn case we went over
last night in November of 2019
government attorney Brendan Vondrak
defended the FBI's decision to
interrogate Flynn at the White House
with no lawyer van Gregg said this quote
the FBI was engaged in a legitimate and
significant investigation into whether
individuals associated with the campaign
of then candidate Donald J Trump were
coordinating with the Russian government
in that same filing Vondrak wrote that
Flynn's phone call with the Russian
ambassador the now famous kiss lyac was
of central importance Gaudi was
imperative that the FBI determine
whether and why such communications with
the Russian ambassador had occurred both
of those statements from Vondrak we now
know conclusively are lies in its filing
this week the DOJ revealed that in early
January the FBI had already known that
there was quote no derogatory
information tying Michael Flynn to the
Russian government
nor did they need to know whether Flynn
had spoken with ambassador kis lyac they
knew for a fact he had because they were
listening at the time they had a
word-for-word transcript of the call
in other words Vondrak was lying in his
filing now this is not only of
importance to Donald Trump the people
who work for him or those who voted for
Donald Trump this is important to every
American because things fall apart
quickly when high-level officials do
things like this for political reasons
look around do you know anybody who
trusts the government anymore there's a
reason for that and it's not good it's
things like this and by the way it's not
just Democrats you should blame for the
corrosion of our public life the vast
majority of the Russian collusion
investigation including the testimony
you just heard the clips we displayed
occurred during the first two years of
this administration who ran the
government then at the time Republicans
control both houses of Congress and
every single committee by definition
they had the power
to expose this hoax and to shut it down
but they did not we can only speculate
speculate as to why they did not perhaps
they were too cowardly to tell the truth
or maybe deep down a lot of them agreed
with the aims of all of this either way
it'll be very interesting and we're
gonna sit back and enjoy it as Lindsey
Graham and Mitch McConnell and Richard
Burr and so many of the other useless
Senate Republicans the total phonies who
tell you they're representing you
but don't explain why they didn't really
do anything to stop the derailment of
America while it was in progress